you posted on instagram this long
caption about going back and forth but
the decision of whether or not to film
the wedding and just so you know the
wedding will be airing here in canada on
hgtv right yes so we're gonna have it as
well
um now that the day has passed is there
a moment you wish the cameras maybe
didn't film
you know i think leading up i'm a
perfectionist and i'm i'm just
you know i like everything to be perfect
i like everything to go smooth i'm i
have high standards with things and so
leading up to it we filmed a lot you
know the process of me finding the dress
the tasting the mock-ups that i need to
talk shopping with our dads and
sometimes when the cameras are on you
know for me i feel like i'm working
right because that's what i do for for
my work and
my life is on tv so
you know a wedding and getting married
to me is
that was the biggest thing
the biggest defining moment of my life
and i've waited to be a wife my whole
life and so it was i was thinking
gosh am i working too am i you know in
my mind am i working and like target
would say babe this the no cameras are
here this is a real mock-up you know
this is our real tasting this is your
real dress shopping so
you know i just had to like make sure i
was out of my head and this is not work
this is my real wedding so
that was i think the hold up for me with
filming it is i didn't want it to feel
like i was working because this is such
a special intimate day
and plus you know
we were very creatively involved with
hetv along the process and they really
took into account what tark and i wanted
because this is our wedding it's special
so they made sure they were fly on the
wall they weren't like up in our face
they were they really respected what we
wanted and we wanted it filmed more just
like a wedding video and not filmed like
a show right so they did an amazing job
and like looking back now i'm so happy
that we captured it because now we get
to share it with the world and and we
get to show you guys a little bit deeper
into our love life and and the process
and hopefully girls can take away
something from what i went through with
my wedding and
i can inspire other women so i'm glad we
did it looking back i'm glad i had a few
moments or i was like i don't want to
film but you know i'm glad i'm glad we
did it now
and looking through the photos that were
posted on instagram
it seems to me there was one person from
selling sunset that i didn't catch in
any photos what was the
well i think i know now watching the
show but
what was your reason at the time for not
extending an invite to christine
yeah you know she was originally invited
to our um
our engagement party and she didn't come
and she didn't even tell me she wasn't
coming so
um it's fine you know we especially
through like quarantine and not being in
the office as much we just stopped
talking and stopped connecting and i got
closer with the other girls and
it wasn't because the other girls like i
saw a few you know a few things where
she said
uh oh i just you know
i'm a jellyfish and i just go along with
everyone else which is not true i am
friends with people that are supportive
of me love me you know i can trust they
care about me and tarik they've been
supportive of our relationship and it
just comes down to i don't trust her as
a friend she hasn't been a loyal good
friend to me and i'm not gonna have
people at my wedding the most special
day of my life with our best friends our
family
so intimate and personal i'm not going
to have people there that i don't
genuinely
love and connect with and want there so
you know it
it's fine like we just we our friendship
has just you know
grown apart and it's okay but
um
you see some you know changes coming up
in the new season so you kind of see us
navigating through things but i i can't
tell you anything about that you'll have
to see but you know it's been a lot of
things off camera as well that people
don't see so it's been a lot of ups and
downs
i want to talk a little bit more about
you and tarek
like just seems so in love it's so sweet
to watch the two of you what does a date
night look like for the two of you
gosh well i feel like now that we're you
know two and a half years in we're
married we're busy with the kids they're
busy with businesses and filming and
just it's non-stop um we don't don't
want date nights that much anymore which
sounds funny but you know nights that we
don't have the kids or
um
you know we have our evenings free we
always try to take our evenings or at
least at night
we sit down together we sit by our fire
pit you know we talk we sometimes
sometimes have wine rarely but we talk
about everything we talk about our
dreams our past our futures our the kids
you know what we want out of our life
and um we've done that since honestly
day one that we met
that we carve out time so that's kind of
like our special time rather than going
out to dinner we like to stay in
be comfy make up off cozy clothes on and
just connect and have quality time
rather than
getting ready going out to a restaurant
dealing with people
um so quality time is very important to
us
it's boring i know but we do travel a
lot we do a lot of fun things but when
we do have that freedom it's like do you
want to go out or should we just order
in or cook in and just be together so we
choose that
the selling sunset has been number one
here in canada for the past week that's
so good
canada loves selling sunset i think part
of it is it's getting cold here and it's
so nice to see like the warmth and
um do you ever have to pinch yourself
and think oh my god i'm on a show that
is like number one in multiple countries
across the world if you ask tariq he'll
tell you like i think i still
don't realize you know how well known
and successful we are and
um
you know i think it took me up till
probably season three
and he's like it's gonna hit you and it
finally did but like but i still don't
stop sometimes to like really take it
all in because we're so busy and you
know i'm always like the next thing the
next thing the next thing and working on
things non-stop that
i need to like sit and be like wow
you know we have accomplished so much
and you know from season one not even
knowing that this show was going to be a
success we thought we'd be off the air
after one season like we didn't know how
it was going to do and
to see where all all of us girls are and
brett and jason are today it's just
yeah i do i need to stop and pinch
myself and realize like the success that
it's brought so um i just life goes too
fast you know
something that i noticed there was a big
difference this season is we saw a lot
more of tarik on the show yes
how does he enjoy filming this type of a
reality show compared to the one he
usually films yeah it's very different
because you know on his show it's more
like hosting and he's in charge he's
teaching people you know how to flip
houses and my show it's kind of a
free-for-all you know it's reality so
the cameras are on and we're just living
our lives and whatever you say
could be out there whatever you do is
out there and you know with his show
it's it's more like you know he's going
in he's talking about houses he's
talking about the renovations he's
talking about the project and this it's
like hours and hours and hours we're on
camera we don't know what's going to be
used we don't know what's going to be
edited we don't know how it's going to
turn out so
it's fun though you know he was at all
the fun events the dog party jason's
party um
you see him a little bit next season as
well um
and it's fun i think people get to see a
little bit more into our real
relationship and get to see a different
side of target that they don't get to
see on hgtv
but i wanted him to stay out of the girl
drama you know i was like
like we obviously have our opinions
about things and i'm like you don't need
to be involved with with this but he's
obviously going to support me 100 no
matter what and tarek is kind of like a
tell it straight kind of guy you know he
just
he he just is a straight-up guy and
he'll tell you what he thinks but i have
to like honey
well i was going to say there was in the
final episode of season four there was a
moment that you i feel we haven't
typically seen on selling sunset where
you walked out of the party with tarik
and we saw a little bit behind
the wall right we saw the setup you're
trying to take off your mic and barks
they're talking you down a little bit
yeah
has it been helpful having him on the
show with you in that sense that you
have a teammate that truly has your back
absolutely because tark and i you know
he knows me better than anyone and we
talk about everything and you know i
leave filming and i tell him how the day
went what happened you know we talk
about things um i talk about obviously
these are my real friends my real life
so he knows the situation with christine
he knows my life with the girls he knows
my life at work and the stress and
and you know the stress christine has
caused in my life and
what she's done to all of us so
you know
in that moment i think a lot of people
you know you didn't see that i had
waited for her for over three hours tark
and i were leaving to go to st bart's on
a red eye
i was already an hour passed when i had
to leave
you know i had the producers had said
well she's going to be here in 10
minutes can you you know please wait and
i said you know what fine i want to talk
to her i want to clear the air i want to
have a nice conversation i might not be
able to have this again for a while
and
so i waited and i waited and i waited
and then she shows up three three and a
half hours late
and then
you know as you see i just wanted to
have a nice calm conversation with her
and she brushed me off and in that
moment it was like
i'm good you know i'm good just kind of
like
she's the one that's been wanting to
have a friendship with me talk to me and
then i try and you brush me off like i'm
unimportant so
i was just fed up in that moment i've
been waiting for hours we were late for
our flight it was stressful for us i had
anxiety i'm like you know what forget it
i'm leaving and that's kind of like what
you saw
and tarek you know
obviously ran after me because he didn't
know what happened and
so you know i think he was trying to
calm me down in that moment and then i
was like you know i want to go i just
want to get out of here like i'm done
you know and
and then as we were walking out we
didn't know the cameras were on us and
then i turned around and i saw and you
know
of course if tark has
you know his opinion and he's going to
support his wife but i also want to make
sure that he's protected because it is a
reality show and you know i didn't want
him to say something that
um would be regretted later on you know
so i just wanted to protect him in that
moment and myself too and then you know
we were just we were just frustrated
wanted to get out of there
it's interesting hearing the complete
backstory of what happened there from
you because obviously we we don't know
that as the viewers
but you're right like you're wearing a
microphone and sometimes you forget
you're wearing that microphone and it
records the entire conversation you just
want to make sure you know this they can
use it in any way they want and that's
why like you know it's girl drama it's
girls you know stuff that you've been
dealing with like i said a lot of stuff
that happened that the viewers don't see
so
you know i don't need him to be involved
with that you know this is something
between us girls in the office he's
going to support me and we talk about
things outside of filming and outside of
work but
you know he just he doesn't need to be
involved
well we we've been touching on it
throughout this interview but
we did see as you've spoken about as
well we see we saw your friendship with
christine sort of come to an end this
season
do you think there is a chance for the
two of you to reconcile in the future
um i think
if i can see loyalty and and that's one
thing like you know
being with tariq he's taught me loyalty
and he's taught me trust and
i am so happy and so in love with my
life we have such positive energy and a
positive happy life and
you know when someone's
causing negativity and distrust and
you know my emotions up and down at some
point you have to release that and you
have to
move on for that negativity and that
toxic energy and i just felt like that's
what she was bringing to my life and
you know i can never believe what she's
saying um she'll send me a text and i'm
and and i'm like well that's a lie
that's a lie that's a lie that's a lie
no it's not no it's not well
you know i think she doesn't know how to
get out of the lies she's telling so
if i can see consistency with her and
loyalty and trust for a long period of
time to not just me but the other girls
on in the office then you know i think
yes and i want her to own up to things
she said and done to everyone um
so i don't know i think it's just gonna
take time and i'm not completely you
know i'm not the type of person that
shuts people out forever like i'm i have
a big heart i'm open-minded and
um i'm a girls girl i love people so
we'll just have to see i think time will
tell
you